So nice to see you again.
It's great to see you too.
Yeah.
I want to say this out
loud, your hair looks cute.
You think it's cute? You like it.
It's adorable.
Thank you.
It's really.
That side flip. You can do that flip.
There you go.
And I can swoon,
What I want to do is keep growing it
till it's like down to here.
And I want to do that thing.
That would be so much fun.
Make sure you invite me
back on when that happens.
(laughing)
I see women do it in
reality shows all the time,
they do this.
Yes.
Yeah, you want to be able to do that?
You're getting close.
I'm getting there.
First of all, you look
fantastic as you always do.
And I'm curious,
first question I ask everybody these days
is how are you guys holding
up during the pandemic?
What's the Obama routine?
What is you as a family,
'cause I know you're
all holed up together.
What do you do?
Well, we've kind of had phases of COVID.
There was sort of the early stages
where we were all excited to be together
and we were being all organized,
and we would spend the days
apart doing our respective work.
The girls were still in
classes in the spring.
And so we would be working and
then doing a little exercise,
then come together in the evenings
and we would have these activities.
We'd have cocktails.
And then we would work puzzles
and play games,
Barack taught the girls
how to play spades.
Oh, really?
Good.
We actually had some organized things,
like we had an art exhibit day
where we all went off and
did like watercolor paintings
and then we showed it.
Now kind of this was in the early stages.
Yes, I'm familiar.
There was a period,
I know that we are going to say,
there was a period of
about a month or two,
maybe two and a half months,
of isn't this a rare
opportunity for all of us
to enjoy each other's company as a family.
Then that went away.
That went away, and it started,
I think first our kids
got a little sick of us.
Which was fine, 'cause we
were pretty much sick of them.
And so the summer started happening
and then we could be
outside a little bit more.
And we came to the
vineyard where we still are
and so they have more room to roam around.
[Conan] Yeah.
(indistinct)
that was good because it
helped us break it up.
And now the kids are back
in Zoom land with classes,
they're doing it remotely and
they are no longer thrilled
about being with us.
No, no.
So (static audio) periodically
for grunt.
(laughing)
How about you and your husband?
Are there moments where
you're thinking we all...
We tend to put figures like
yourselves and your husband
up on a pedestal and we forget
that you too can have
moments of Oh, it's that guy.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
We've talked about this.
Yeah.
The thing Barack was finishing his book
as it was just announced
that his books are going to be
published after the election.
So he actually spent most
of the summer locked away
writing the book.
So he's had limited time
to get on my nerves,
but then he sort of
has gotten on my nerves
because I haven't seen him enough.
He can't win.
He can't win, he can't win.
We all know that.
We know that we can't win and we got it.
I would think you would
have some sense of,
Hey, excuse me, guy.
I wrote my book a long time ago.
Huge hit, massive, massive hit,
huge book tour.
What's taking you so long?
Do you ever get to do that to him?
Well, his book is a little
bigger, a little more,
little more historical as he would say,
but yeah, we've managed,
we're still together
and he's still alive.
(laughing)
That is the perfect sign
that we're making it through
I think I would have
read about it somewhere
if you two had split up.
(laughing)